[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
that has left the show you want to tell
them you also you tried to start your
own merch line and I called the police
that's not it Ben okay let me try again
we're gonna miss from producer
extraordinaire man Ben Avery swinging a
Miss are you suing me are you suing my
wife's family I swear to God they send
these dirty pieces of [ __ ] but get if I
do the thing where I bring up your
behavior then now we're back in the
cycle so I have to I have to pretend
that I'm the big piece of [ __ ] well the
comments like Ben should die people like
you and people that grew up in places
like you did are going to have to feel
pain now thanks Ben it's please go up
more
I mean here's what's amazing here's what
these podcast producers don't realize
they've all won a lottery Ben really
doesn't do his job this is very
interesting Ben really doesn't do his
job if he had set the mic up in the
beginning but he had set the mic up in
the beginning you'd be fine he coasts
and all he does is complain that he has
to travel I mean him and his wife can't
get drunk thank you Ben you don't have
to Telegraph what you're doing you can
just deliver do you ever feel like you
work too hard
check check test
a little fake it's a Clapper so I can
see the thing and then sink I mean it's
a pretty big [ __ ] up but you're people
gonna have your head for this let's just
say all podcast producers anyone can do
your job I hate that we're rolling I
know we are it's the Tim Dillons can you
sit in your chair and do the show where
are you going I wish Ben was killed by
the Russians and not you well there's a
lot of boxes I really like oh my God
will you tell us about some of them you
[ __ ] [ __ ] everyone's very
disappointed in your behavior right now
I think you're even disappointed in your
behavior right now Ben Avery announced
on Instagram Monday that he is no longer
the producer of the Tim Dylan show
saying I've been receiving a lot of
messages and comments about this so I
wanted to say something officially
unfortunately I no longer work on the
show as of the last few weeks I'm
extremely grateful for my time with the
show and what has meant to so many
people I wish nothing but the best for
Tim I'm also thankful for the support
from all the people that have emailed
and messaged me over the years or have
met me in person it means a lot to me
I'm working on some projects now and I'm
excited to share them with you all as
soon as I can Ben Ben has left the show
we should get that's the big news oh
that was a big news that's the big news
best no longer with the show yeah no we
love Ben and we wish him well and it
wasn't over money he was offered a lot
of money to stay but he wants to do
other creative things
he doesn't want to be a giggler I gotta
respect that you know stay tuned for the
next Ben Avery project whatever it is I
mean God bless him and I I you know it's
not over money so I do feel like he I
said hey here's a shitload of money yeah
do something you don't love to do
anymore and because for me I go do it
take the money right but for him he has
this Morality In This code where he's
like I don't want to use you for money
I'm not happy and and I you know maybe I
created a hostile work environment with
you know and I'd say shut up to him on
the show I didn't mean shut up I meant I
don't want you to talk at first most
people thought this was a joke including
myself it seems like some sort of long
bit that they would pull off Olivia
Sienna said please be a joke did Tim try
to grab the wrong microphone everyone
listening to this already thinks there's
an article coming out in the LA Times
with a crying Ben Avery I mean everyone
already there's no one not thinking he
was right there's nobody listening to
the show right now that does not believe
he was molested right no way it
certainly seems real at this point but
it makes sense why we thought they might
have been joking I mean this seems like
something that Tim and Ben might do some
sort of long ruse it fits the dynamic of
the whole show Tim constantly [ __ ]
on Ben saying that he's sabotaging the
show pretending to fire him looking for
new producers it makes sense why we
thought this might have been a joke but
it seems real at this point russoop said
Tim fires him every couple months I just
can't take Tim seriously so I can see
him telling Ben to do this we'll see if
it's real I could totally see Tim
telling Ben to make this long like
statement saying that he's no longer
with the show and then him being back
the next episode but we do know at this
point that it probably is real finally
Tim can run the show without someone
trying to sabotage him at every turn Tim
finally drove this poor Jewish boy
insane and Tim seems like a bad boss to
me so that's kind of like the dynamic
that they've always had and it's
honestly one of the best parts of the
show I think when Tim is mean to Ben it
makes me laugh every time because I I
figured that they're all in on the joke
I've taken [ __ ] from people
for no money right I've
like abusive or whatever but I do think
on the show The bit the dynamic of me
always being shut up and Mia I mean Did
You observe any of that semi-famous Ryan
yes but I thought it was part of the
interplay part of the banter yes I shot
him in the leg once now that wasn't part
no it was I think it was part of the
banter but no matter how much somebody
wants to say it's part of the banter
Louie so when I told Louie Louie was
like oh yeah Louie goes it's always so
funny right when you tell him to shut up
but Louie goes oh yeah I knew that guy
was gonna quit because he probably goes
home and his wife's like why do you let
him speak to you like that but it's
every dynamic in radio the producer
always sucks yeah go back to stern go
back to anywhere you're always [ __ ]
on the producer this is not new I didn't
reinvent the wheel this is just kind of
the fun Dynamic I we spend all our time
together I get mad at him he'll get mad
at me it's just the dynamic of two
people that spend a lot of time together
one's kind of this cranky curmudgeon
once a young sweet boy and I'm like kind
of being like shut up what do you know
about life no not everyone was upset
with this news actually there were a few
people saying that the show's been stale
for a while that's been time for a
change time to switch things up that
maybe this has run its course with Tim
and Ben this guy said the show's been
pretty shitty lately not gonna lie and
now I see why love Ben so much the show
will never be the same without him the
Rob into Tim's Batman Ben commented my
favorite Ben Avery moment was when he
left the show maybe this is Ben Avery's
burner account actually and I ejaculate
fire said it did seem like the show's
definitely gone downhill now I know why
I am going to do my thing it's still
going to be a solo show we're bringing
in new producers to hired a new guy yeah
who's really good the show needed a
little bit of reinvention right because
it was getting stale and Ben I think
quit two years ago but he kept coming in
and that I respect Tim also mentioned
that the constant traveling and Road
life of the job might be a reason why
Ben was unhappy with his role he was
also newly married so that's got to be
hard to make both things work if I can't
give you a lot of money I don't know
what to do I can't make you feel better
I can't make you a comic he wasn't a
comic and you know you're sitting next
to a comic there was a lot of travel
sure I think that kind of War on him he
had to go to Australia that's terrible
London awful horrible places and you
know what do you guys saying like he's
the Liverpool cheaper place to me but it
was still like a nice but I think it
wears on the marriage I get it I get it
and he's not a comic so he's not getting
what I get out of it right so he's not
walking on a stage and entertaining
people for an hour so here's the deal I
I think everybody's got to live the life
they want to live and somebody might
want to go I don't want to giggle right
like that's not what I want to be known
for I don't want to be a giggler like I
don't want to be a guy who just sits
next to a guy but now that the news has
confirmed that Ben Avery has actually
left the Tim Dylan show a lot of Comedy
fans are left wondering what their
relationship is currently like Master
coach said not sure what the drama is
but hopefully all parties are in good
terms wish you all the best vid kid said
[ __ ] end of an era and no one took
this news harder than Cal Howell who
said this news has me more upset than
when I was arrested for some weed [ __ ]
can love Ben I'm just gonna pray that
Tim and Ben are trolling either way I'm
heartbroken LMAO
thoughts go out to Cal in this trying
time now we listen I love Ben I I'm
there's no ill will I want Ben to have a
great life Ben and me have had you know
a major impact on each other's lives
right like we became really close
friends we did a lot of cool videos you
know he was part of the rebirth of the
show in La like when I went out there to
live like he's been there for a lot of
crazy moments in my life and I do love
him and um I respect whatever he wants
to do because you do you get one life
personally I'm gonna miss Ben Avery on
the show I really enjoyed the dynamic
that Tim and Ben had together it must
have been rough to basically be a
lunatics punching bag for a living but
someone had to do it it made all of us
laugh so cheers to you Ben Avery you
truly are good but will he become a
patreon member I I'm sure that he
probably has a subscription or he's
gonna have to if he's not paying that we
usually reset the patreon so the
password doesn't work anymore well
should I give myself
we come up with a tier X producer where
he has to pay like five thousand a month
ex-producer tier it's just one
additional abuse of them yeah it's just
one episode from me to him telling him
to go [ __ ] himself I'm like I know
you're listening to this you piece of
[ __ ] this is the one above the
Rothschild sit down tell your wife it's
time for the monthly [ __ ] you force him
to take his purpose Severance back yeah
yeah my business manager is like hello
Ben as part of the severance you'll be
given several weeks of your salary also
Tim has stipulated that for one episode
on the patreon every month he will
insult both you and your wife and you
will have to listen to it you'll have to
record yourself listen to it like I
should make a stipulation where it
literally has to sit there and have a
camera on him for an hour while I just
scream at him
thank you for watching this video
subscribe to joke world right now if you
haven't and please for the love of God
go follow us on Instagram we are 400
people away from reaching 10 000
Instagram followers I know it's so
stupid to care about Instagram followers
as much but come on we have 130 000 on
YouTube and we're still in the nine
thousands on Instagram we're posting
similar content you guys would like it
if you like this video If you like this
channel go follow us on Instagram and if
you DM us we'll send you free stickers
in the mail
[Music]
foreign
[Music]